c'est toujours en route pour la ryder
cup la ryder cup qui se rapprochent de
nous à moins que ce soit nous qui nous
rapproche sur dell vous savez que c'est
la compétition la plus médiatisée au
monde après les jeux olympiques la coupe
du monde de football et ne savait
qu'elle oppose les états unis et
l'europe
[Musique]
au sommaire de cette émission l'invité
marc assous à 14 ans il vendait des
bonbons sur les marchés il a lancé des
radios produit des spectacles musicaux
il a créé le salon du golf qu'il reprend
cette année portrait d'un homme que les
golfeurs vont t'adorer la découverte
dans ce numéro visite du golf blue green
de saint quentin en yvelines le témoin
on l'appelle le sculpteur du golf depuis
plus de vingt ans il aa liénard de la
sculpture et sa passion du golf ses
oeuvres sont désormais incontournables
rendez vous avec hubert privé matériel
il arrive depuis quelques années sur le
marché du golf ce sont les clubs
japonais continuent de différent des
clubs américains classiques réponse avec
mathieu césar eaux du golfe du bois de
boulogne enfin comme chaque mois dans
par soixante dix huit le conseil du pro
[Musique]
l'invité de ce numéro sevelen du salon
du golf il l'a créée il ya quelques
années il le reprend cette année il aura
d'ailleurs lieu les 11 12 et 13 mars
prochains à la porte de versailles il
s'appelle marc assous et je vais le
rejoindre
marc assous bonjour bonjour ça va
écouter je suis ravi d'être là ça me
fait vraiment plaisir génial alors on va
parler évidemment du salon du golf qui a
vu le 11 12 et 13 mars prochain un tout
petit peu beaucoup vous êtes le
fondateur le créateur et que vous avez
repris cette année mais mais vous avez
quand même un parcours absolument
extraordinaire vous de la production
vous avez écrit radio voltage voltage
ffm est alors comment on arrive de deux
là qui est quand même assez lointain au
salon du golf que vous avez créés parce
que ça n'existait pas non le salon du
golf n'existait pas ce qui était génial
à l'époque c'est qu'on me disait mais si
ça existe salon non ça existe je vais
regarder quoi regarder et ce qui est
génial c'est qu'en fait ce salon je les
crée en 2007 et on est en 2017 oui ça
fait dix ans donc ça fait donc dix ans
11e édition plus tôt mais c'est vrai que
le début c'est quoi ça se passe comment
un soir
en allant manger chez mes parents chez
ma mère mon frère me dit qui est un
golfeur de lille 20 ans il me dit tiens
tu toi tu organise des salons est ce que
tu sais où je pourrais trouver au nos
salons du col des clubs de golf est ce
que c'est moins cher j'ai dit je sais
pas je vais voir si si ça existe mais ce
qui laisse à laon puis en fait y avait
pas de salon du golf et donc j'ai donné
ma démission avec mon pote jean françois
et vous laisse j'ai fait et j'ai créé
voilà votre frère volet des clubs donc
vous créez le salon du golf c'est aussi
simple que c'est un peu
alors vous l'avez créé en 2007 vous
l'avez ensuite vous êtes parti à nouveau
dans la musique et la production et la
musique c'est un peu ma passion et je
suis très axé comédie musicale et c'est
vrai que j'ai été approché grâce encore
au golf puisque c'est un monsieur qui
s'appelle hervé tayeb que tout le monde
conneries sur chaumont j'ai quitté le
golf de sûrement avec 101 voilà qui est
très copain avec gérard presgurvic et il
me dit tu sais gérard il a besoin de toi
etc et puis bon bah je rends service à
gérard sur certaines opérations de
communication parce que j'adore la comme
j'adore la pub je suis havrais
communicants et j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
faire ça et à la fin gérard presgurvic
me disait combien je te dois gdba et
coûte 0 un jour tu me rendre un service
i et puis en 2013 voilà j'ai envie de
repartir dans la musique et à partir de
là je remets en place un système et
jeudi gérard presque s'il te plaît toi
t'as roméo juliette file-moi ta bande
sonore je vais à l'export et je balance
prometteur à l'étranger et c'est ce
qu'on a fait et ja personne avec qui
vous avez rendu le sens du gauche
voulait arrêter quand rouen bat paul
paul était fatigué c'était vraiment son
métier il adore le golfe y joue au golf
c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup
et que je connais depuis très très
longtemps vous avez décidé de reprendre
le savent en tout cas voilà et j'ai dit
à paul paul je veux pas que le salon
soit vendu à n'importe qui n'importe
comment ça fait trois ans que j'ai
laissé le salon du golf on est à un an
de la rider c'est un c'est quelque part
un bébé que j'ai créé je ne veux pas le
reprendre je ne veux pas le laisser à
n'importe qui et vous l'avez repris et
gelé repris et alors là un truc génial
cette année c'était que vous allez
offrir à tous les gamins étaient douze
ans entre 7 et 12 ans tous les gamins
qui se présenteront au salon du golf 11
12 et 13 mars je leur offre un sac de
golf et je mets en place un practice
d'environ 500 mètres carrés donc aussi
grand club practice de callaway ou ou de
cleveland ou de wilson fin des autres
marques je mets un practice de golf je
mets des petits green je mets des
prouesses je mets des pros pour leur
dire voilà les copains voilà les gamins
voilà on va rigoler ça va être sympa le
golfe on a à peu près une dizaine
d'écoles avec des gamins qui vont venir
et j'aimerais bien qu'on trouve un tiger
woods quoi voilà c'est l'avenir l'avenir
de l'avenir du golf français va se jouer
les 11 12 13 basse
au salon du golf si vous permettez on
viendra faire la prochaine démission
selon avec plaisir franchement vous êtes
les bienvenus et parce que là c'est
formidable c'est vrai que là il faut
dire il ya tout ya le matériel il ya les
voyez le salon a grandi et s'agrandit on
a à peu près une trentaine de nouveaux
exposants donc ça va être énorme et des
produits qui ne sont jamais jamais
jamais 11 12 et 13 mars il rappelle la
porte de versailles vous avez fait le
salon dure vous n'êtes pas golfeurs
cédant jusqu'à beau-frère par expand
suis pas du tout d'accord bon ben on va
quand même vous faire un petit peu petit
à petit but de faire appliquer comme ça
montrera sa un pro il vous donnera des
ddd conseil avec
[Musique]
non je retrouve d'autres pros préféré
sébastien huissier qu'il coach de
l'équipe numéro international ou au golf
national on vous a concocté un exercice
un peu particulier un peu différente
d'habitude puisque marcassus notre
invité pas voulu prendre un club ou un
ferr ou en bois il prendra potter donc
on va parler de petit robert peut-être a
bien fait partie du job élément très
important c'est vrai c'est très très
important
c'est là qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde
souvent on est bien d'accord un peu
dangereux est ce que je vous propose
c'est de tout simplement le faire un
petit rappel des fondamentaux simple
pour avoir un petit défi car on a les 2
3 1 qui fout qu'il faut respecter vos
biens peta est tout à fait bonjour à
tous bienvenue on change un petit peu de
sujet on va traiter le compartiment du
putting donc j'ai observé un petit peu
ce que faisait monsieur assous au
coaching on voit qu'il a besoin d'un
petit peu de technique il a une tendance
a heurté un petit peu la balle ce qui
provoque des problèmes de dosage en fait
simplement voilà on sait que lorsqu une
accélération trop prononcée dans la
frappe on perd le contrôle de la phase
deux clubs là c'est également de la
vitesse première des choses le
positionnement de la balle par rapport à
ce que j'ai pu observer donc d'éviter
d'avoir une malle vers le pied droit
avec un club chirac du coup en
descendant qui écrase la balle on va du
coup ramener la balle plus tôt
en face de l'ex de la colonne away le
point bas du mouvement tout simplement à
partir de la gestion pour moi du dosage
au putting c'est déjà la gestion de
l'amplitude une gestion d'amplitude qui
va se faire par une action des épaules
et une vitesse constante de tête de
clubs au niveau du sol ok donc pour
avoir un dosage assez régulier et
efficace parce que je préconise c'est ça
c'est cette constance de vitesse par un
mouvement qui est dirigé par l'action
des épaules et on va jouer sur
simplement l'amplitude en fait voilà
exercice tout simple là j'ai placé un
petit repère ses outils ça me sert juste
à vérifier que j'ai bien l'oeil gauche
au dessus de la balle et une petites
sardines avec une ficelle ça c'est
vraiment pour me donner des repères en
fait pour être sûr d'être positionner
correctement par rapport à mon objectif
simplement l'exercice sera le suivant
simplement se positionner ici je fais un
premier puck l'objectif est de passer le
trou à peu près de 40 cm on va dire
voilà pour faire simple
et donc je vais d'abord rechercher ce
mouvement des pôles avec quelque chose
d'assez en tout cas pour ma part
symétrique au niveau de la tête de clubs
et avec une vitesse constante donc
l'objectif pour lui est de maintenir
cette vitesse constante
et par contre l'arrivée à déterminer
quelle est la bonne amplitude pour
arriver au trou
[Musique]
le golf que nous allons faire découvrir
dans ce numéro c'est le golf de la base
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le golf blue green de 50 ans dit il dîne
avec sa directrice sassi modérant
bonjour ça c'est mon jour patrice vous
êtes la directrice du golf de la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines de
golf qui appartient à bourg green tout à
fait qui est un des fleurons de blood
and ailleurs il est né à peu près cordon
les années 80 plus précisément
1981 donc ça fait un peu plus d'une
trentaine d'années maintenant qu'il
existe à l'existence atteint 9 seront au
départ nous aujourd'hui on est sur deux
18h18 on qui ont été refaits avec des
buts qui ont été remises en place et on
a six trous complémentaires pour toutes
les parties pour les personnes un
enseignement citron compact alors oui
c'est ce qu'on appelle une golf public
c'est dire que on peut venir sans être
abonné forcément juste pour jouer
exactement aujourd'hui on n'est pas
obligé d'être membres ont peu joué je
dirais la prestation donc ce qu'on
appelle un green fille ou être abonné à
l'année sur 12 mois vous avez 3 700
abonnés on a 700 abonnés ici et puis on
a en plus de ça peu près de 150
personnes qui sont en formule
enseignement qui ont des marchés nous
donc chaque année pour arriver à avoir
une carte verte et commencer à jouer
faut dire qu'il ya quatre ans c'est dur
oui on a quatre enseignants qui sont là
donc on va dire séjour ce têt pas les
quatre en même temps mais bon ils sont
tous les jours il ya des enseignants qui
sont disponibles tout à fait alors on
parlait de ça justement ont aussi parlé
des greens vie puisqu'il ya donc les
abonnés les graines fils avait compté
combien de degrés depuis par an alors
par an on est sur une base de 25000
green filles et à peu près
entre 5 contre 55 milles départ
d'abonnés en plus des 25000 green fille
alors vous le disais tout à l'heure il
ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent ici
pour débuter de golf parce qu'il ya des
enseignants qui peut les prendre en
charge on a beaucoup de gens qui
débutent puisque on fait partie de la
chaîne bluegreen donc et plus
spécifiquement ici à saint quentin on ne
fait partie d'un golf dit évolution donc
on est vraiment sensible à tout ce qui
est débutant donc on organise deux fois
par an des journées portes ouvertes et
donc suite à ça on a ce que je vous
disais à peu près pas là les nouveaux
golfeurs et des personnes qui rentrent
dans une formule d'enseignement chez
nous mais ça n'empêche pas aussi qu'il y
avait offert ils sont là pour essayer de
bonnes équipes on a des bonnes équipes
on a des équipes seniors navy un kit dam
des équipes hommes qui sont je dirais
plus haut niveau régional mais quand
même qui restent de bonnes équipes tout
à fait là ce
parfois on est frappé quand on vient ici
quand on parle un peu avec les gens qui
jouent c'est une sorte de convivialité
ces gens ce qu on se trouve oui tout à
fait effectivement aujourd'hui malgré le
fait qu'on ait énormément de passage les
gens se connaissent entre eux mêmes que
s'ils jouent en semaine s'ils sont
adhérents ou pas adhérent les gens se
connaissent et il ya une convivialité
consent l'ensemble du club alors vous
êtes aussi au centre de battre saint
quentin enfin
quand
on est au sein de la base de
sa aussi skds qu'il ya des passerelles
parce qu'il ya des gens qui veulent la
piscine est ce que des souris aux
entraîneurs puissent encore compliqué
c'est encore un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui on voit au niveau des
habitants de la communauté d'agglo qui
ont du mal à connaître je dirais du
moins deux à venir bronzer prévenir
c'est surtout ça c'est oser venir
là on va essayer dans peu de temps sur
les vacances de pâques de faire un
jumelage entre la voile dont qui est
aussi sur la base de loisirs est ici
donc le golf d'essayer d'amener des
enfants en initiation sur les deux
activités donc pour essayer de mixer un
petit peu tout ça alors évidemment il ya
des compétitions il ya des missions
classement il ya 20 ans on a des
compétitions de clubs sort on a des
compétitions de placement semaine des
compétitions cassement week end
on a un club
seniors qui est très actif qui jouent
tous les mardis tous les jeudis et donc
voilà donc on a appris aussi de la place
pour les autres teams souhaite pas faire
de compétition tout à fait montre tout à
fait deux parcours il ya le bleu et le
rouge les deux groupes ii par contre 18
ans c'est quoi le différencier naquit
plus difficile qu'une autre alors on a
le parcours bleu qui sera un petit peu
plus long un peu plus haut voilà plus
franc par contre le parcours rouge sera
beaucoup plus technique plus court est
pas et qui aura des places et se voit là
il y aura des greens plus étroit cette
fois oui donc il est là il y en a un peu
pour tous les goûts y en a pour tous les
goûts les gens qui viennent du
changement les changent volontiers de
parcours c'est à dire que souvent
surtout nos abonnés quand ils viennent
par exemple une journée jouée sur le
bleu la fois d'après ils iront sur le
rouge pour alterner donc il ya 30 ans et
vingt neuf trous aujourd'hui à 36 trous
42 avec le contact le convaincre qu'est
ce qu'on peut souhaiter pour les 30 ans
qui viennent ce serait bien qu'ils aient
un petit peu plus de golfeurs et que ce
soit un sport un peu plus démocratisé
aujourd'hui est ce que vous entendez
parler de la ryder cup au 8 août a fait
aujourd'hui la ryder cup
les gones parole c'est juste à côté sur
le golf national donc les golfeurs en
parle d'accord on parle beaucoup
maintenant ce serait bien aussi qu'au
niveau de la population ne sont pas non
plus connaître ce bel événement qui va
avoir lieu dans peu de temps chez nous
donc le message qu'on peut donner c'est
balayer pas peuple poussé les portes de
venir ici vous serez bien accueillis
tout à fait et très bientôt nous aurons
nos journées portes ouvertes du
printemps donc à partir du 24 mars à
24,20 de mal à 4 bars venaient tous
venez tous au golf de saint quentin
voilà merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
cette tour eiffel ryder cup devant
laquelle tous les étrangers qui viennent
découvrir le parcours du golf national
se font photographier c'est une oeuvre
d'un scooter qui s'appelle hubert privé
hubert privé c'est le sculpteur du golfe
il a fait du golf sa source
d'inspiration et c'est le grand témoin
de cette émission
bonjour hubert privée dont je veux ça va
bien très bien car vous n'êtes que le
sculpteur du gop le plus connu on est à
côté d'une de vos dernières oeuvres on
voit bien le symbole les états unis et
l'europe je vois que je vois que le
travail qui a été réalisé et vole bien
une des
des grandes actualités de la crosscup
ça commence et de comment vous êtes-vous
d'abord dessinateur industriel tout à
fait ouais bah oui j'étais pendant mon
enfance j'étais pas un élève
excessivement brillant donc à l'époque
on nous mettait un peu un peu dans les
duels garage exactement les métiers
manuels je me suis retrouvé à faire
pendant cinq années de de la métallurgie
et du dessin industriel et puis après il
ya aussi d'être du travail avec
l'industrie de luxe ouais effectivement
j'ai j'avais la chance d'avoir pas mal
d'idées et et dames et les belles choses
et donc j'ai travaillé pour les grandes
maisons du luxe en france comme chanel
chaumet 0 puis zèle toute sorte de
maison comme ça alors comment es tu
arrivé la sculpture de golf dans votre
vie en fait c'est le golf est arrivé
déjà bon alors je partage beaucoup de
valeurs de ce sport on pourrait en
parler pendant des heures vieux vraiment
je suis quelqu'un de passionné de et qui
parle du golfe comme et enfin pour moi
il faudrait tout où tous les êtres
humains puissent voir moi le golf c'est
la vie quoi et donc tout ça ça m'a donné
envie à travers mon travail de deux
sculptures de
d'exprimer de raconter le golf à ma
façon en fait donc je me suis mis à
faire des boules avec des têtes de club
je suis un peu du détournement ouais
c'est ça au départ en tout cas oui les
sources d'inspiration aussi c'est à dire
que je sois sur un golf soit le paysage
que ce soit les réflexions des joueurs
les attitudes et tout ça c'est des
sondés source d'inspiration que j'essaie
d'évoquer dans dans mes sculptures
et aussi tout ce qui est actualité et
tout ce qui est acté c'est vrai qu'il ya
des sculptures très connu et notamment
il ya eu cet art sous on a vu par
exemple tous les joueurs de l'open de
france qui passait qui se faisait
photographier il ya la tour eiffel ryder
cup alors là c'est un must il ya des
oeuvres qui vous sont plus auquel vous
êtes plus attachés que d'autres ah ouais
j'ai quand même les mets fameux 3 tible
blanc totti le bourget à l'arrivée du 18
qui sont maintenant sur le rond point à
l'entrée un autre et d'une grève
nationale qui sont vraiment des oeuvres
de parts déjà le titre parce que ça
s'appelle les jo-2018 les géants arrivé
en fait moi je suis tellement admiratif
de tous ces grands joueurs et passionné
que voilà il fallait que j'évoque
quelque chose qui leur ressemble et
c'est à cette époque là aussi que j'ai
commencé à faire des oeuvres
monumentales comme mon panier géant
cometti géants comme dans toutes sortes
de pièces comme ça qui évoque qui évoque
justement tout tout ce que représente le
golf c'est à dire le travail la passion
le bain toutes ces choses là à quoi il
faut il faut il faut c'est important de
dire que cc c'est une activité qui est
le reflet d'une vie aussi quoi je pense
qu on est obligé de travailler au golf
sans arrêt alors vous êtes connu en
france est évidemment mais vous êtes
maintenant que dit aussi un
international vous êtes dubaï notamment
voyagez beaucoup se dirige vers les
états unis c'est vrai que maintenant le
voilà dans le monde entier entre
retrouver des oeuvres du père privé oui
mais j'ai osé aller montrer mon travail
un peu partout et puis j'ai des
journalistes des spécialistes de l'art
qui ont fait un peu des recherches il
s'avère que ils ont
ils ont après après le salon mondial du
golf vi d'orlando là cette année ils ont
déclaré que mon travail était en fait
unique quoi j'ai cette chance pour la
seule à priori à priori sur le bon dans
l'univers des pays où il ya des golfeurs
apparemment il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'artistes qui qui travaille dans mon
style qui font des choses comme moi quoi
dans ce livre s'appelle golf privé
golf en privé lalaurie de l'ice et c'est
un concept assez la maison parce que y'a
vos oeuvres et puis vous avez demandé à
des gens comme ça de faire des petits
textes autour de ses oeuvres et donc on
retrouve évidemment aux sculptures et on
retrouve un peu parfois de l'humour
parfois de la poésie dans les légendes
qui sont qui accompagne ses oeuvres et
là vous travaillez sur quoi en ce moment
je objets jeu je travaille sur mon
implantation au maroc aux états unis
donc je suis en train de travailler sur
différentes pièces j'ai aussi des
grandes maisons qui commence à me
demander des cheveux beaucoup enfin de
plus en plus de trophées aussi j'en
mesure où ils veulent avoir une oeuvre
importante pour pouvoir marquer au lycée
le voile a symbolisé l'événement et
marques et les noms des vainqueurs tous
les ans avec des répliques donc j'ai
aussi des demandes maintenant dans ce
domaine là bravo et merci beaucoup merci
on ouvre maintenant d'autres séquences
matériel traditionnellement le matériel
de golf du matériel américain mais
depuis quelques années on voit arriver
sur le marché des clubs venus du japon
qu'ils ont des clopes parfois plus haut
de gamme parfois presque fait main
quelle est la différence entre ces clubs
américains et ses clubs japonais on en
parle avec le responsable du fis tic de
golf plus au golf du wat boulogne
j'ai rejoint mathieu cesaro bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le responsable du
fitting de golf plus au golf et
l'hippodrome du bois de boulogne est
jeune et qu'on parle ensemble de
nouveaux clubs conquis arrivera ça fait
un petit moment mais enfin les clubs
japonais qui arrivent sur le marché qui
de plus en plus présent alors que
pendant longtemps c'était les clubs
américains qui dominait le marché ça
fait conserver une sainte huit ans à peu
près ça fait une petite petite dizaine
d'années que le marché japonais rappi
petit à petit départ en europe les clubs
américains et plus sur un profil de
distribution qui va correspondre un
petit peu à tous les joueurs toutes les
personnes qui se mettent au golf donc
avec des clubs plus accessible en termes
de prix en termes de matériaux aussi qui
vont être utilisés
qui vont permettre d'avoir des coûts de
fabrication qui vont être moindre jeu
des clubs dits japonais avec tout cas
point plutôt haut de gamme premium
aujourd'hui en fait les marques
japonaises travaillent énormément
portier le énormément de légèreté très
peu de déformation à l'impact et avec
des aciers d acier qui sont utilisés
pour les têtes du forget faut savoir que
les japonais ont cette culture du
formulées par la fabrication des sabres
japonais les katanas ils ont cette
réputation de faire du faux relais d'une
extrême qualité litres alors on peut
peut-être regarder quelques calculs club
pour un petit peu comme ça ça c'est des
marques américaines exactement les
titulaires l'été le remède les cobras
aubrun les pires après on a des clubs
qui sont plutôt qu'ils vont se
positionner comme les marques
américaines mais qui sont japonaises
telles need you know jack à même si la
honte à ces classiques exactement mais
on trouve quand même des qualités dans
le forget
qui sont propres à mizuno ils ont les
joueurs aiment toucher mizuno qui est
propre à cette marque dacca et après on
va voir les marques japonaises
proprement dite ou on à aulnat xio 6 ou
ses six tonnes c'est ça c'est du groupe
strict sonas regza faut savoir parce que
c'est un nom comme ça américain mais ces
japonais c'est le japonais aeon maquis
électrique classique
exactement ça fait c'est une vieille
marque japonaise qui a toujours véhiculé
une image de faits main artisanat et
boundiali sont ils exactement alors ça
ça existe pour les faire ça existe aussi
pour les bois n'avaient naturellement
exactement du potter en passant par l'ol
les faire les hybrides les bois et les
drivers je n'ai pas cité callaway wii
qui qui vient tout juste de sortir une
gamme qui est exclusivement réservée au
marché japonais on va retrouver
encore et je voulais que exactement
c'est la gamme bêta qui ce qui s'est
focalisé sur le besoin de légèreté la
facilité de jeu le confort qu'on va
retrouver qui sont un petit peu à
l'image des clubs japonais on va
retrouver sur la gamme bêta tchèque est
là ouais non je dirais qu'on
ça parce que ça c'est très intéressant
là on a un club titres américains et qui
ce qui fait main c'est ça exactement en
fait
c'est tout nouveau sur le marché c'est
la gamme pgs on est sur des du fort j'ai
fabriqué au japon tout le restant est
assemblée en l'occurrence pour cette
marque en france à la main à la colombe
et ça rien pris par exemple pour un sas
entre gars on va être entre du 3 ou 4
étoiles on va être au tour des 2000
deux heures entre 1500 et 2000 euros le
driver on va voir un nouveau souffle sur
le marché après comme vous le disiez
c'est pas parce que un art où x you où
les marques attendant
japonaises sont plus légères que ça va
fonctionner pour tout le monde demande
on est des gens qui ont besoin de plus
de poids dans leur club vous savez ce
qu'on va là conseillé cette année aux
figues exact revenir ici à longchamp
voilà merci beaucoup métier césar où
elle s'appelle perrine delacour c'est
notre plus sûrs espoirs sur le lp de
gier elle joue avec une balle avec une
jolie fleur et aujourd'hui elle est avec
nous dans l'astuce du champion pour les
potes en descente bonjour bonjour alors
perrine ce peuple de 10 mètres en
descendent raconte nous c'est tout
simple il suffit de prendre un point
intermédiaire à mi-distance 60 m ici
juste là
je ne vais ni ralentir ni décélérer et
je peux te la balle pour aller à cinq
mètres et ensuite la balle prouvera
jusqu'au trou
bien jouer perrine merci
alors sur ses petons descendre c'est
quoi l'astuce c'est simple c'est peut
être la moitié de la distance c'est
simple
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]